Epi phenomenalism is the claim that the
contents of Consciousness indeed
Consciousness itself
has no effect on anything in the
physical world
mental events may arise because of
physical ones you feel happy because
certain neurotransmitters like serotonin
exceed a particular threshold say or the
sky seems blue to you because particular
cone cells in the retina are excited by
particular photons of light but the
reverse is never true
physical events do not arise because of
mental ones only physical events cause
other physical events the physical world
follows deterministic laws know the laws
and know the conditions initial or
otherwise of the particles in the
universe and in principle everything
follows as a matter of logical necessity
everything is thus determined
predetermined if you like at the moment
of creation that was the Big Bang so we
have at least some thing coming from no
thing physical reality came from
something that wasn't that or rather
existence came from non-existence
something came from nothing at least
once anyways even if you believe in God
you think that God came from nothing he
just always was but in the case of the
big bang and the universe we know that
it had a beginning because
all the lines of evidence point to a
particular solution that the Universe
had a beginning it has not existed
forever the universe does not stretch
backwards in time indefinitely Or
infinitely
it had a beginning all of physical
reality did so the universe came out of
nowhere or physical reality did or
existence did put it how you like the
beginning of everything thus sets in
stone every other thing that ever
happens anywhere ever until the end of
time on the physics and metaphysics of
mainstream determinism what place
therefore is there in this world for
stepping outside of the purely physical
we may have mental events curiosity Joy
fear love excitement tension contentment
happiness and all of their opposites and
more but not one of them has any actual
effect on anything in the physical world
because they are not physical they are
mental they are just experiences
happening in the minds of a certain kind
of higher ape
insofar as happiness exists in the world
it exists in truth on this account
solely as a certain blend and
concentration of Serotonin dopamine and
other neurotransmitters across many
synapses in a human brain and it is just
what it feels like to have that amount
of those neurotransmitters
the feeling itself of those chemicals in
the brain has no further effect it is an
epiphenomenon in other words now that is
a terrible explanation in one foul swoop
it seems to try sweeping away the
explanation of any mental or conscious
phenomenon by saying nothing is
explicable nor does it need any
explanation
in other words
here we have a problem what is this
thing Consciousness why should a
particular concentration of Serotonin
and dopamine or any other blend of
neurotransmitters feel any way at all
why should the sky look that color blue
or the grass that color green
why should chocolate taste as it does
and nothing like smoked mussels
all of these qualier epiphenomena
but calling them Epi phenomena is just
avoiding the problem
it's not a solution it just says of all
this problem there is no solution those
Sensations and the capacity to have an
experience of the world at all do
nothing to the world they serve no
purpose they exist for no reason you are
on a train through life and you've no
choice but to follow the rails what you
experience you experience necessarily
all was fixed long before your birth on
this view it was fixed at the beginning
of time and now the particles which
constitute the universe of which your
body and brain are composed follow
trajectories set at the start of all
things your choice is therefore are
illusory your experiences epiphenomena
but why
why should the universe be so
constituted as to contain epiphenomena
and in what sense do these Epi phenomena
exist if the physical is all there is
why does anything feel like anything at
all why should the Blue Sky look just
that Hue of blue why should anyone be
aware of it why can't the universe just
evolve without anyone experiencing
anything
sometimes all of this is labeled the
hard problem of consciousness
why should anything seem any way at all
in a deterministic universe described by
objective physical laws what place is
left for subjectivity
why should drinking alcohol or coffee
feel a particular way feel good to many
people why should anything feel good
except that it motivates people to do
what feels good to pursue pleasure and
avoid pain but what possible place can
motivation have in a deterministic
universe
where everything is set in motion and
set to happen at the beginning of all
things
why should anything be motivated to do
anything in a universe where motivation
is not required for things to get done
unless that is not everything is
determined at the Big Bang maybe some
things are created later and some things
will be created only if entities are
motivated to bring them into being so
being motivated to pursue Joy or
pleasure and avoid pain and suffering
can help be one of the causes for an
organism to survive or at least it's
genes too
sure it's not perfect in evolutionary
terms we humans among other creatures
are liable to overdo it on alcohol and
sugar in particular among other things
but why is any of this Pleasure and Pain
stuff there at all from an evolutionary
standpoint in evolutionary terms because
it seems to facilitate problem solving
pursue pleasure avoid suffering these
are good survival heuristics for a
person now I am a thorough going
determinist but I want to suggest a form
of determinism consistent with what we
know of reality as it is that salvages a
purpose for Consciousness in the
physical world on this topic I have
spoken and written before I wondered
then if Consciousness and creativity
were the same thing the fact is that not
only do we experience the world but we
can even agree about some of our
experiences this is not to say that what
I see as blue is identical to what you
see as blue or what you feel is Joy
feels identical to what I feel is Joy
but if we are both down on our luck with
bills piling up and buy a lottery ticket
in a moment of exacerbation only to win
against all the odds we feel Joy now
maybe your joy feels different to my joy
I don't know but that we both enjoy the
feeling we both find it a positive
experience of some sort this is
something we share in terms of evolution
this explains why most Foods taste good
and most toxins are bitter but again if
all is predetermined why should any of
that be needed why should sugar taste
sweet an old milk sour
Evolution had to create that knowledge
of what things taste like organisms
attracted to sugar found energy more
reliably and passed on their genes those
that did not avoid the sour milk got
sick and possibly died by consuming
toxin producing bacteria
senses allow for Sensations to be honed
so organisms can reliably move towards
what was more beneficial while avoiding
that which would do them harm
but the Epi phenomenalists can argue
either the taste of sugar just is a
physical thing sugar is sweet is more
than just a description on this account
it is more like a necessary truth of
some kind sweetness on this view has no
subjective aspect to it that's an
illusion it's a manner of speaking when
such things are said all I can retort is
that to my ear I do not know what they
are talking about if it's just a matter
of speaking a manner of speaking
nonsense I would say nothing about the
shape of the sucrose molecule Cries Out
sweetness here particular receptors had
to evolve in tongues and certain ideas
encoded in brains for that to follow
or the epiphonomalists can argue sure
sugar does taste sweet but it's not the
tasting sweet that causes people to more
often seek out sugary things that's an
illusion
people are just doing things because the
laws of physics determine they will
sugar sweet taste has absolutely zero
effect on your having a second bowl of
ice cream
that second bowl of ice cream was
determined to be eaten by you at the
beginning of time but was it if it was
then I can see the epiphenomenalists
having a point
they may still be wrong but they have a
point it would be unnecessary for any
experience to be an experience if pure
physical determinism or physicalism were
true in other words anything that
happens to a person and happens to have
Sensations associated with it those
Sensations the subjective content of
experience serve no purpose
they exist
they do nothing but what if you're
having a second bowl of ice cream just
was not determined at the Big Bang
what if you as a person did things
because you wanted to what if that was
the true explanation
now on the everything happens because of
some prior cause account of the world
backwards in time to the beginning of
time then you're wanting anything has no
effect on what happens your want the
feeling of Desire is again an Epi
phenomenon
it just comes along for the ride without
serving any causal purpose in the world
but what if it was not
if it really is not then your want your
desire really is the reason you have the
second bowl of ice cream and you do so
because it's sweet and maybe you've a
sugar craving after a 10 kilometer run
and you wanted to do the run because of
the second bowl of ice cream you had the
night before and you're beginning to
look like a guy who enjoys a second bowl
of ice cream a little too often in other
words you have your reasons and at the
level of physics what if it's possible
for you to literally create an idea in
your head
like how about I have another bowl of
ice cream
what if no set of neural firings prior
to some idea ever determines some of
your ideas
they originate entirely within you you
are the one who has those ideas they
arise spontaneously in some sense in you
like a spark
but you create them you are the Creator
you are the knowledge Creator nothing
else is the cause of the idea but you
this would mean that physical reality is
so constituted that not all information
or knowledge is there in any sense and
determined to be there in reality at the
Big Bang even given perfect knowledge of
the physical laws and initial conditions
at that moment not only is knowledge yet
to be created inherently unpredictable
before it is created but even in
principle it is not determined to be
created in a very real sense precisely
because of what to be created means
it means it is not there in some other
form or any form prior to it coming into
being prior to the act of creation and
in particular The Act of Creation
occurring in the mind of a person Epi
phenomena are on any account a bad
explanation
a better explanation is consciousness
and its contents facilitate the creation
of knowledge
creation this knowledge was not there at
the Big Bang in any form knowledge
Creation in particular explanation
creation is creation xnelio of a Kind
sure it's not entirely ex-nilio in the
sense the Big Bang itself seemingly was
but it is other kind if not identical to
what apparently occurred with all of
physical reality
what I am saying is we people are the
equivalent of a kind of singularity
from one Singularity came all of
existence
but from others come ideas so it is not
so ridiculous to claim something can
come into existence out of nowhere
as I have said as we have already
observed so far as we know the entire
universe all of physical reality came
from nothing what if the universe itself
can contain entities within it from
which things can also come from nowhere
from The Singularity that existed at the
moment of the Big Bang came everything
what if the analog of a singularity
exists in the mind of a person and this
initiates ideas
what we are doing moment to moment is
encountering problems
we experience joy and we strive for it
and contentment and kindness and we try
to avoid suffering and boredom and
cruelty it would make far more sense if
Consciousness and its contents were
there to guide us in solving our
problems moving towards good and away
from evil finding paths to make progress
and increase Joy while reducing
suffering
to do so we need to create explanatory
knowledge ideas about what is and what
might be
on this view then the sweetness of sugar
the blueness of the sky emotions of fear
and love and all the rich contents of
our subjective experience of the world
serve a causal role they are not Epi
phenomena but key to the literal
creation of knowledge they are the why
about why we create knowledge
we have a problem because we are curious
or we are suffering or we want to have
more fun what if and here the conjecture
becomes admittedly a little more wild
the Big Bang contained within it all
that was needed to determine that
entities would arise in the universe
whose Behavior was not determined by
anything that happened at the Big Bang
the Big Bang brought into being a
universe that obeyed physical laws those
physical laws apply to everything in the
universe but as we often hear they break
down when applied to what's happening
inside of for example a black hole if a
black hole were a naked Singularity so
it is said perhaps TV sets could come
out of them and the reason because the
regular physical laws as we understand
them break down inside such
singularities our understanding of
causation fails TV sets may as well come
out of such things therefore because
regular laws of physics do not seem to
apply we don't understand how they apply
not very well
so what if people are the only real
naked singularities what if TV sets can
come out of people
after all in truth they did TV sets came
from the imaginations of people it's
either that which at least explains
something or television sets came from
the first Singularity that which
inflated and expanded at the moment of
creation
from that big bang event came hydrogen
Stars galaxies planets people and
eventually television sets so television
sets come from singularities whether
that's the big bang or something in the
mind of a person make your choice
but one of those is merely predictive
the other at least contains the nascent
beginnings of explanation